two months have brought a lot of change
this is video of russia's flagship
vessel in its black sea fleet the moskva
when the russian military released the
video back in february it was a show of
force now it appears to have been a sign
of overconfidence
according to this ukrainian military
spokesman its forces hit the ship with a
missile it started a fire and the ship
started sinking the russian military has
a different story it isn't acknowledging
any attack saying simply there was a
fire and the ship had to be evacuated
when ammunition started exploding it's a
big blow to russia washington hasn't
confirmed either story but the u.s
national security adviser says it looks
bad on russia whether it was an attack
or an accident what he calls
incompetence and neither is a
particularly good
outcome for them
russian officials are pushing their own
supposed success stories the spokesman
claiming the last 24 hours their
aircraft hit seven military facilities
in eastern ukraine
that region is very much now the focus
for russian troops in particular the
donbass region the port city of mariupol
appears to be close to falling under
russian control if it hasn't already the
ukrainian foreign minister says the news
coming out of the besieged city is hard
to hear
to unblock marijuana and to save them
literally to save them
we need
weapons
[Applause]
now canada is one of the countries
helping with those weapons but the
deputy prime minister said thursday
there's also a focus on war crimes
[Applause]
rape is being used as a weapon in this
war we are not going to forget
and we will work with ukraine
and with our democratic allies around
the world to bring the perpetrators to
justice
now on the western side of ukraine
tensions appear to be tightening the
netherlands thursday showed off four
f-35s it's now deployed in bulgaria to
reinforce nato's eastern flank with
russia our coalition operations sent a
strong signal to the russian aggressor
that chose to invade a sovereign
european nation
moscow meantime is pushing back it says
it's watching the buildup on its borders
and says its defense ministry is working
on plans in response
mike armstrong global news